chers amis vous êtes grossier goujat mal
embouché vous êtes gauche en société et
les portes du grand nombre se referme
devant vous quel dommage voici quelques
conseils qui vous aideront à tenir dans
la société
la place qui vous est normalement dévolu
et qui feront de vous un convive de
choix et apprécié de tous premier
exemple vous entrez dans un lieu public
avec une dame ne fait pas on me dit non
mais tu ne se pensait ou et qui c'est
qui paye merde alors suivez plutôt notre
formule modèle conseil après vous germa
d'affaires feria merci et en plus c'est
agréable lorsque vous rencontrez une
dame ne lui serrerait pas la main d'une
manière rustre comme un vulgaire paysans
des carpates
c'est la poule alors ça gaze un baiser
la nuit vous êtes toujours à table chez
vos amis et un besoin pressant bien
naturel vous surprend soudain ne dites
surtout pas voir fogel parce que c'est
vraiment un long moment pour pouvoir
mais suivait au contraire notre formule
modèle conseil audit dont chère madame
belhout est pris donc le téléphone s'il
vous plaît merci
dans une telle situation cependant à un
incident fâcheux peut toujours survenir
par exemple la maîtresse de maison peut
avoir oublié de garnir les lieux où
quelqu'un ne dit pas suivez plutôt notre
formule modèle conseil et avec le
téléphone jamais les mots tendres
vos amis ont préparé un plat que vous
n'aimez pas plutôt que de vous rendre
malade ce qui serait stupide n'hésitez
pas à refuser catégoriquement le plat
qu'on vous propose
mais attention utilisé pour cela une
formule correct ne dit pas mais j'en
veux à cet effet toutes les stratégies
parmentier
utilisez plutôt une phrase fine et
courtoise qui saura toucher votre
interlocuteur de plus que j'ai vous
votre père sur son lit bord j'ai un
blocage sur la tête de veau
la conversation au dîner a été un peu
ennuyeuse le repas a été copieux vous
avez tendance à vous assoupir quand vous
vous réveillez sachets sauver la face
avez vous lu le dernier et de l'isf à
jean-rené vu les met pas évitez les
formules de style 1 arrive au cola et
plus le minervois le béret bonjour
sortez vous en plus tôt par une
pirouette qui fera la joie des grands et
des petits
paris paie son ego cours à la bleue
c'est un métissage harlem et vous
empruntez déjà orléans merci c'est là
que je descende
vous êtes un convive agréable aimé de
tous malheureusement vous avez un petit
défaut vous avez les pieds qui gonfle et
oui et cela bien sûr peut gêner vos
autres lorsque vous êtes obligé de
retirer vos chaussures ne dit pas dans
ces cas là et ailleurs est jamais bien
parti puis les pieds
utilisez plutôt notre formule modèle
conseil
je suis un peu gêné voyez pas ce que
j'ai la voûte plantaire un peu
souffreteuse alors j'utilise mls crawler
qu'elles sont chargées au bout de trois
mois alors vous trois mois faut les
changer c'était justement j'ai envie que
je t'avais échangés hélas à l'épicier
des fermes et gilles en chercher un coup
de téléphone à l'encontre j'étais
obligée d'aller au bureau j'ai pas pu
échanger tout est pensé jets d'objets
dans le tiers les fonds baptême comprend
les voilà maintenant un dernier conseil
leur paraît bon votre voisine de table
et charmante l'ambiance est chaleureuse
la conversation d'un très haut niveau
intellectuel
malgré les gaudriole et les bourgs a
tantôt bref le digestif et exquis vous
n'avez pas envie de partir mais pensez
un peu à la malheureuse maîtresse de
maison qui a eu une journée fatigante et
difficile et qui tout à l'heure aura du
mal à nettoyer son plat à lasagnes au
dessus de l'évier
alors n'hésitez pas ne vous éterniser
passer vos amis sachez partir est
utilisé pour cela l'une de nos trois
formules modèle conseil ouah c'est pas
tout ça mais comme yann et hong kong
maritain bonne visite et porte
jarretelles jeu sera pas semaine
prochaine merci ma couleur rouille et
pas les qualités mais émet des quantités
je file chine - et les bicarbonate dans
les pharmacies et vous qu'est ce que
vous diriez fayyad et on regardait la
dire quand la bouffe est dégueulasse
alors tu vas marché va gratter moi j'ai
rejoint mes copains au bistrot faingaa
soit bonne ou mauvaise manière faite
jour amène tout petit la vaisselle